français la parole est à monsieur arnaud
robinet madame la ministre de la santé
j'ai un scoop pas vous annoncer j'ai une
nouvelle précédent à vous annoncer
la canicule arrive au milieu de l'été et
la grippe saisonnière arrive au début de
l'hiver
j'aurais aimé poursuivre dans l'humour
si l'épidémie de grippe n'était pas
aussi grave
si le retour des médecins n'étaient pas
aussi alarmant madame la ministre vous
avez vous même reconnu que le bilan
serait probablement lourds comme vous
dites
nous n'avons pas encore atteint le pic
de l'épidémie que déjà les chiffres sont
inquiétants
trois millions de personnes touchées des
causes de mortalité de 25 à 30 % dans
certaines régions des hôpitaux engorgés
et pour finir 6 millions de journées de
travail perdues soit un coût de 900
millions d'euros
madame la ministre je vous accuse
d'inconséquence car nous avons déjà vécu
une épidémie de cette ampleur durant
l'hiver 2015 qui a fait 18 mille morts
or au lieu d'anticiper la crise
d'aujourd'hui vous préférez comment
telle hécatombe d'aujourd'hui à
conséquence toujours quand vous ordonné
aux hôpitaux saturés de déprogrammer des
opérations alors que cette dernière le
sont déjà
avec ou sans grippe saisonnière j'ajoute
qu'en reportant ses interventions ce
sont des coûts supplémentaires que vous
pourrez supporter à vos successeurs
enfin je vous accuse de cynisme cas
certitude à sion ne serait pas aussi
grave
si le gouvernement n'avait pas faibli
avec autant d'acharnement notre système
de santé
vous avez fragiliser la médecine de
ville mise à l'écart les cnil privé vous
avez et attiser encore un peu plus les
hôpitaux
vous n'avez quasiment rien fait en
faveur du virage ambulatoire en faveur
de la santé numérique ni en faveur des
médecins doit-on s'étonner du nombre de
morts chez les personnes âgées qui on
sait que 70 % des périodes soignants ne
sont pas vaccinés
oui madame la ministre les français
veulent et paye aujourd'hui le prix
d'une politique de santé idéologique
technocratique et inefficace qui cachent
la vérité aux patients alors madame la
ministre
merci la parole est à mme segol
secrétaire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées et de la lutte contre
l'exclusion
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
arnaud robinet je pense que le sujet de
la grippe pourrait appeler un peu plus
peut-être de pondération et peut-être
aussi de consensus sur ces bancs parce
que somme toute il s'agit d'une maladie
infectieuse que l'on peut prévenir par
la vaccination et je m'en dit quelques
mots parce que comme chaque année il y a
eu une grande campagne de vaccination à
l'automne
organisé par l'assurance maladie et le
gouvernement
et je voudrais émettre un voeu pour
l'automne prochain
je voudrais qu'à l'automne prochain tous
autant que nous sommes dans les
fonctions qui seront les nôtres
eh bien vous parlions tous autant de la
grippe et de l'importance de la
vaccination au moment où il faut se
faire vacciner parce que je n'ai pas
noté vous avoir beaucoup entendu au
moment des campagnes de vaccination ou
rappeler l'importance de cette
vaccination et de la prévention de cette
pathologie infectieuse
pour le reste la ministre de la santé a
effectivement demandé aux hôpitaux de ré
ouvrir des lits et de rappeler des
professionnels ce qui est fait à chaque
fois qu'il y à des événements qui font
qu'il y à un afflux particuliers
notamment dans les services des urgences
l'objectif étant bien de pouvoir
hospitalisées toutes les personnes qui
nécessitent une hospitalisation et
autant la situation pourrait être plus
tendue la semaine dernière
autant le point qui a été fait ce matin
par les ministres de la santé montre
bien que la situation en tous les cas
dans ce qui est des hôpitaux publics est
moins tendue et il ya moins de personnes
qui ont à ce jour besoin d'être
hospitalisée il ya plus de jeunes qui
ont besoin de soins mais pas
d'hospitalisation
en tout état de cause je voudrais dire
une chose tout ce que vous dites est un
peu contradictoire avec le
ce soutien votre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle parce que supprimer 500
mille postes de fonctionnaires supprimés
des dizaines de milliers de postes à
l'hôpital public
eh bien oui c'est complètement
irresponsable et ça serait désastreux
pour l'état de santé des français
mr